let's draw an isosceles triangle if the
triangle in which two of the sides are
equal to each other and we had seen in
the previous video that it has a
vertical axis of symmetry if this part
is flipped to the other side we see that
the two parts match exactly and that's
why we say that this shape is
symmetrical this is called reflection
symmetry why is it called that let's see
if we take one part and keep it against
a mirror we will get the original shape
the reflection of one part completes the
shape but wait what is the other kind of
symmetry do we have another kind to know
the answer here's another figure for you
this figure is made up of six squares to
be precise now I want you to tell me if
this shape has reflection symmetry or
not can we draw a line through it such
that the two parts formed match exactly
with each other if we try out different
lines we realize that no such line can
be drawn this shape has no reflection
symmetry but what the shape has is
rotational symmetry yes rotational
symmetry what does that mean as the name
suggests
let's try rotating the figure about its
center point and what does rotating
about a center point me take the example
of this triangle if we rotated about its
center point it will rotate like this if
we rotate it about this point
it will rotate like this and if we
rotated about one of its vertices it
will rotate like this the shape will
rotate differently depending on the
point around which it is rotated now
let's come back to our figure we rotate
the figure completely around the center
point once and see how many times it
looks exactly like the original one
rotating it completely means rotating it
by 360 degrees let's have a counter on
the right which counts the number of
times the rotated figure looks like the
original let's start now
cigarettes at zero degrees after
rotating it by 90 degrees we get the
shape it's not the same as the original
the counter is still at zero okay so
let's rotate the original shape by 180
degrees and we see that it looks exactly
like the original shape it fits in
perfectly BC an increment of one on the
counter we continue rotating it till we
finish one complete rotation rotating it
by 270 degrees gives us the shape which
is not the same as the original and
rotating it by 360 degrees gives us the
original shape back the counter changes
to two what does this to tell us it
tells us that when this figure is
rotated completely by 360 degrees the
rotated image looks exactly like the
original image twice once at 180 degrees
and another at 360 degrees so we say
that this shape has rotational symmetry
of order two to recap when do we say
that a shape has rotational symmetry
okay this is long so I want you to
listen to it carefully a shape has
rotational symmetry if it looks exactly
like the original shape a number of
times when rotated about the center
point by 360 degrees here the number of
times it looks like the original is 2 so
we say that this shape has rotational
symmetry of order 2 is it easy to find
the order of rotational symmetry let me
give you a few shapes and why don't you
try finding their order of rotational
symmetry first and over looks like this
next a square an equilateral triangle
and a circle each of them has rotational
symmetry but we need to find the order
we begin with the oval shape and start
rotating it let's see how many times the
rotated image looks like the original
one and twice we saw that it looks like
the original shape two times after the
complete rotation its order of
rotational symmetry if two in a similar
way why don't you try finding the order
of rotational symmetry for these three
shapes let's start rotating the square
now about its center point 90 degrees
180 degrees 270 degrees and 360 degrees
clearly the order of rotational symmetry
for a square is 4 now for the
equilateral triangle 120 degrees at 240
degrees and at 360 degrees three times
in one complete rotation the order is
three and now we come to the circle what
do you think will be the answer here no
matter how we rotate the circle it will
always match the original shape it will
have rotational symmetry of order
infinity so remember a shape has
rotational symmetry if it looks exactly
like the original shape a number of
times when rotated about the center
point by 360 degrees
[Music]